four to shoot Wiggins has to go Wiggins
pull-up jumper no Townes a rebound
budget fly at Carl Anthony towns drills
it at the buzzer a catastrophic finish
for the Grizzlies
here's another look Townes what great
awareness to get him out of his hands
and he got it away in time they will
count the bucket won't a Morris to yo
catch in the leg
[Applause]
Pepsi Center patient just great two-man
game pick and roll give it back to his
best player make something happen
doesn't look pretty but none of his
shots pills that they go down and give
you a two-point lead and how about the
assists by Monta Moors right on the
money you guys used to plan together
working together
true true port use the closest one came
up to a contested Rose loses the baskets
what man problem get that shot out here
dive on the loose ball welcome project
yell [ __ ] in the pile here again
[Applause]
deeper
Edgar is done it in a close game again
off-balance leaning for the first time
all-star yogic with the key winner
who's that pressure against him kind of
liked a martial arts move these their
aggressiveness against them
maytag's there's like somebody
highlights it's hard to keep up
[Applause]
maybe he just takes this and takes it to
the class and cuffs it game is
confidence now Nicoli okage don't work
on deadly gonna power it up behind the
back miles off the glass yes oh what a
password hey beautiful
no look behind the back pass for Nicoli
opens he was the open dunk that play and
then the rebound that went out of bounds
of the wage aggressively going after the
ball
speaking of aggressive while Anthony
towels with authority when he shot who
would take it for Denver it's Jamal on
the Joker
yo get to the lane shows it up
[Applause]
hurt his knee one of the two he has
limping back to the huddle and this is
just pure touch bird gave it to him
really nothing open three-point attempt
to a season he's Doug Begley in the hole
right back at you Timberwolves built in
early 12-point lead Bradley kind of
started it and then watch this long pass
he doesn't even get it to the other hand
Kinzua back to town go to the free-throw
line here
slice it in half market is the only
player in double fingers
[Applause]
well did the message happen that's each
happened behind the back you see the
contact right there and reach in also
and somehow Knox is shot down all these
nice young players like these players
that you go to the front of the room in
towns finds him fancy but it's so
effective again towns just off the block
and he creates and has so much it's
trying to find their offensive rhythm
here
Nikola on the drive pass it out great
pass to Morris who knocks it in
somebody's got no charge was alone in
the corner momentarily tap says I'll
just handle it from here
that was crazy gone back to town look at
the defenders who are coming to collapse
on towns the floppy floater flew out of
bounds water polo class Beasley
how about that fear can't assist and
watch this kid thus it's time to turn
over please eat us run Minnesota fell
asleep
Liggins nearly got there but oh what
pass over the shoulder my task to a
cutting charge sire this runs right into
the chest of Julius Randle again nice
Cuddy
[Applause]
he's trying to stay on his body actually
jump in other words he showed remarkable
restraint Jones inside four towns always
face the nation Wow they got it down to
10 and Denver brings the starters back
in and Murray and Joker and to it 24 for
Murray 18 for yogurts that's the end of
the first half
nugget 66 sits advantage in the quarter
so far close out the quarter
Victoria Craig maybe get back in this
ballgame if he does check in this place
is going to go crazy
just look at this pass break to the
final five hole she was right at the rim
there to build the key to come right in
the face Yogesh hand off to Merced
everybody's getting physical a different
or not responding Yogi's coming in
[Applause]
[Music]
town gets around Weibo oh my goodness
karl-anthony towns on the fall look at
town with the snow bass line underneath
the hoop in Carlson's second quarters
now into yoga show kids to to shoot as
they know it and put it up quick scoop
it up and in so just a fourth shot for
the Joker in the game so far really
short hate is the guys can have an
impact in this league started this
little two-man game he was anticipating
a little cut down votes to paint this is
nicely done Derrick Rose to shoot fern
fadeaway got it Nicole eoq it's the
Joker tape Morris
here's that fadeaway shot clock going
down a little dirt Nowitzki right there
Bayliss finally gets it into town but
that just destroys the rim right now
karl-anthony towns in the tip rolls on
the short end of a six-point game
the baseline bandwidth the body
no good
keep vision in towns and maybe even
double off the post
and wrote it down see that's what makes
me want to play is those type of plays
that make you miss basketball be helped
by the sexton now yoga shot clocks at
3:00 know the Joker going to his bag of
tricks just when he takes that steps I
mean look at the space the difference
between
widely from five to shoot town
attacking go back does slam it down
world there he just put that on the deck
and with the left hand in their last 34
close on him and he stuffs it through
put him in the dunk contest and a run
out wasn't enough yoke it's five point
he feels it to pick his try to kill him
Coco ghee has made have to come to the
confidence Department oh my goodness
confidence not a problem for Carl at the
town's gets hammered as he throws down
the jam in towns where they don't want
to go here in the third gets he gets
angry and that's what it takes and he
got hit oh right in the face and you
know was that a flagrant foul
Marcus all hit him well here we go four
to shoot yo kids gonna take he needed
the bank to be open and it was the last
eight points going to the Joker
excellent job by pulling it out there in
hedge on Andrew Wiggins get back to his
own town trying to take advantage with
yo kicks out of the game just abused to
basic greatness right there on the part
of karl-anthony towns who might have got
away with a little bit of a hook here
too with the off arm he kind of got into
the chest earring right there get out of
my way
hold it off move go get three to shoot
placed it up got it beautiful shot
picked up by Simmons
[Music]
[Applause]
and then in transition
the reach-back Katmandu
not on that one I'm just looking for
another hoop this time down yo kids for
three Nicoli go kids from sophomore way
downtown gonna go out there's this the
swing is in phase one of being able to
find that scene if you don't put a body
on him like all great offensive
rebounders I love it
I see
[Applause]
: we'll drive all the way off the window
got it
tough shot off Pink's up from the left
side right-handed that's a tough shot
it's gonna dribble over the shoulder of
Paul George times wives it up and throws
it down
finishes with 14 points person 41 points
and 14 rebounds in an emphatic
Timberwolves win over the Oklahoma City
Thunder pull it back out again set up
[Applause]
[Music]
barp and moment they're of course the
stakes not nearly as high did he get up
for that slam away from the Wizards
because we wouldn't see this point is
having none of that
yoke it's got to go quickly here with
one on the shot clock and over the
backboard on this one looks like your
old teammate Harry Bird right I mean
look at that shot that's gonna be on
bzees dogs right back I think they call
it the cows listen to the broadcast he's
trying to prove something out here
second quarter he goes baseline hauling
bushes and yes we call that a reverse
jam any ground after the double would
but can we see the first dog sat for
about four minutes and the Nuggets
outscored the Spurs 7 3 with the okage
down and yoghurts a little 1 foot allows
at home
instant offense from Macola yo kitchen
he's got eleven now six call the timer
look at that Brian one-legged step back
tough shot to rinse to toast furnace
[Applause]
dicken I came out green he's just a
tremendous defender Tom's gets back
through the front McCullum scoring the
ball as well as 10 in the second half 13
for the game flurry amused by yolk it's
so pretty
d anytime they are not gonna let Carl
Anthony towns hurt David post up
situations saach-- it's one of those
dances get out of here rookie
karl-anthony towns he knows he knows
that Luca wants to get to the rim now it
goes to cancer and finds Morris on the
wings Yost gets with one to shoot folks
it up and in what did we tell you though
right this guy was just 30 more touches
absolutely dynamic all year
fake get that defender committed put it
on the deck big fella rolling he's gonna
get double figures points and he has the
ball so much most likely got hammered on
captor made baskets
- how about off of a made basket good
job of throwing the ball ahead towns
finishing over Adams take that shot
clock down to four here goes Murray
gives it up yo kids pass this up on a
three now he'll take a long two and
another one off the window the second
time tonight that Joker has hit the
glass from straightaway what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content